more often than not these are the
stereotypical images the developed world
associates with Africa but global lock
downs have challenged this with more
time on their hands viewers worldwide
have been accessing a diverse range of
content like the South African drama
blood and water I've been living with
this ghost my entire life snapped up by
Netflix earlier this year it was one of
their top 10 most watched series in the
u.s. last month
what are your past Netflix as Dorothy
ketubah says it shows Africa in a
completely different light what's really
interesting is is a showcasing black
talent on screen you know it's it's just
beautiful to see and and in this day and
age of black lives matter blood and
water has truly shown that black lives
do matter
series is a teen drama with all the
usual tropes of the genre but the
mystery being solved is far more serious
that of human trafficking I still am
pinching myself just to be a part of
something so big doesn't make you one of
the people just makes you a joke 20
year-old Koshien gamma is the show's
breakout star I think it's really
important that you know we're being
given this platform to control the
narrative and you know tell African
stories to the world you're making the
biggest mistake ketubah says technology
has effectively rated the world
borderless
someone can visit South Africa because
of watched blood and water but use the
power streaming that is the power of
putting content in people's hands South
Africans have also used technology to
unleash the creativity available at
their fingertips just ask the stars of
the movie cabin fever produced entirely
during this country's pandemic shut down
weren't enough actors turn their cell
phones into cameras their homes in two
sets and shot all their scenes
themselves closer in the surcoat Abady
are a couple in real life who also play
a couple locked down in their own
apartment in the film you know or
telling a good story man can can break
down a lot of borders yeah we were like
a huge car selling this genuine human
story yeah yeah because that's how you
relate you know you can only relate to
somebody on a human truth real people
with real lives
want to say that look we are more than
the starving we are more than the civil
wars we are this human people who greed
we live we love our town for CBS this
morning Saturday Debora patta
Johannesburg South Africa